thank you for joining us America we are
glad you are here open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you can follow me on Twitter if you'd
like at Dave Ramsey Dave what are some
of the challenges of living without a
credit score you know the challenges of
living without a credit score are very
low unless you're trying to buy things
that you don't have the money to buy if
you don't have any money living without
a credit score is a lot tougher in other
words so I haven't had a credit score in
years because I'm a borrow money in
years I mean like decades
I don't own a credit card I have just a
couple of pieces of plastic in my front
pocket I have a debit card on my
business a debit card on my personal
account my driver's license in my
handgun carry permit those are the only
plastic I carry and then I carry some
cash I travel a lot we travel abroad we
do a lot of work related travel we rent
cars we check into hotels we do all of
that with a debit card I buy things
online with a debit card I have almost
no trouble with a debit card any more
than you would have with a credit card I
have to use good sense just like you do
with a credit card in terms of the don't
interface with websites that aren't
secure and so on you want to use good
sense but I can do everything in my life
that you can do except go into debt and
I probably could actually go into debt
even though I don't have a credit score
because of my net worth an income but I
mean I'm pretty bankable would you guess
but uh but I don't have any desire to do
that you know where you run into
problems shoot out of the chute out of
the gate with a credit score is really
three areas when you're broken just
getting started
one is to rent some places they want to
see a credit score lots of landlords
rent to you without a credit score I'm a
landlord
don't require a credit score to rent
from us I do require some you know
references and I want to see some
evidence that you have paid bills and
can pay bills but it doesn't require a
credit score to rent from us and there's
lots of landlords that will rent to you
if you have no debt and you're just out
of school and you got the new job and
you know there's a reason you don't have
a credit scores because you haven't gone
out there and borrowed a bunch of money
which actually means you can frickin pay
your bills and so you're actually a good
renter the second area is to buy a home
with a mortgage without a credit score
it's difficult but it can be done you
can call our people we've advertised and
been our sponsor for 20 years
churchville mortgage and they can get
you a mortgage without a credit score
now you have to have everything else in
line you have to have a good solid
downpayment you have to have a good
steady time on the job you're not to be
not buying too much house as a ratio of
your income your payment and those kinds
of things it's kind of an old-fashioned
idea we used to do when I first got in
the real estate business thirty years
ago we used to actually mortgage
companies actually used to underwrite
the loan meaning they would verify your
deposit they verify your employment they
would verify your how long you paid your
landlord earlier on time and you know
there weren't there was no such thing as
a credit score they just actually looked
at the human being and said this track
record of this human being makes common
sense as a lending process and that's
called manual underwriting today and it
can be done the third biggest complaint
I get for people they don't have a
credit score is renting a cell phone as
a brand-new adult and you've never had a
cell phone and you walk in and you want
to rent a cell phone and you're 19 years
old or something or you want to buy a
cell phone and sign up for service
they're going to require a large deposit
that you get back in a year and and
they're going to give you all kinds of
hassle because they're not used to doing
it and they're a pain in the butt now I
don't run into that because I have like
80 cell phones or something like that or
90 cell phones that our company owns and
they're furnished to our team and so we
have a large contract you know and so I
don't personally run into that if I get
rid get a cell phone I just we
put it on this massive corporate account
that we have and it's not a big deal so
I don't personally run into that one
anymore and you know once you've had a
cellphone with a carrier for a while
then the deposit is fully returned and
usually it's a year and it could be like
a thousand dollars or something but
other than that you really don't have a
lot of trouble oh you can run into
trouble renting cars from some companies
with a debit card when you don't when
you haven't arrived at an airport in
other words if you want to go up in your
hometown without having arrived by
airport and just rent a car with a debit
card some of them won't rent to you most
of them will but some of them won't
so you run into a little bit of trouble
with that but it's really very minor
compared to being freakin in debt to
your eyeballs and paying all your income
to a stupid bank and interest coming out
your ears all in the name of having a
credit score
stupid America it's stupid so the offset
is very minor the the minor hassle
factor in return for having a freaking
life that wasn't stolen by a bank it's a
great offset it's a great offset and so
I'm amazed at the pushback I get I mean
I get hate mail cuz I tell people to
cover their credit cards what a world we
live in you people are weird some of you
some of you people are nuts
I get hate mail because I tell people
not to borrow money to buy a car I get
hate mail cuz I tell people not to buy
whole life life insurance or go to a
payday lender I get hate mail it just is
amazing to me we bail it we get so much
of it how good a Christian there is what
Christian tells people not to get ripped
off stupid bird why is this hard
this isn't unbelievable in but it's out
there dude I'll tell you that
and so it's like it's so weird everybody
worships the altar of the great FICO and
so God forbid someone should challenge
and say hey FICO has no clothes the
emperor has no clothes it's mythology
it's not an indication of wealth
building your
FICO score only says you borrowed money
and paid it back it's not an indication
of your net worth or your income or your
savvy with money all it says is you paid
bills and you were stupid enough to go
into debt so that later you could go
further in debt by building up your FICO
score which is a false measure of
financial health
FICO has no clothes the emperor has no
clothes I dared to say it I'm the one
that stood there I'm not going along
with the crowd I'm not a little rat like
animal that runs over the cliff with the
rest of you that's called a lemming I'm
not doing it and you shouldn't either
you need to look around you and say hey
what is the average typical person who's
freaking broke doing and do the opposite
the average typical person has a student
loan that's been around so long they
think it's a pet they have American
distress they've discovered bondage a
master card who named that anyway and
they got Visa coming out their ears in
addition to that they got fleeced car in
the driveway and payments on their
stupid bass boat give me a break
this is the average person in America
and they bought a house on a thirty year
adjustable rate mortgage because that
was the only way they can afford the one
with the jacuzzi and the skylight
because god forbid we should ask how
much we only ask how much down and how
much a month so that's normal in America
70% of Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck normal in America is the number
one cause of divorce in North America as
money fights and money problems
normal is America normal in America is
our retire and I say I hope the
government which is well known for its
ability to handle money will take care
of me who wants to be flippin normal
normal sucks well you don't want to be
normal if you got any sense I don't want
to be normal
owner I want to have a sense of destiny
with my wealth I want to live like no
one else so later I can give and live
like no one else by the way I refuse to
apologize for succeeding helping other
people succeed if you don't like the
fact that I have succeeded helping other
people succeed bite my butt America
seriously so here's the deal don't be
normal
be passionate go in there change your
life if you're broke friends are making
fun of your financial plan baby you're
right on track
if fat people are making fun of your
diet you are right on track if
somebody's been divorced 16 times says
you're too nice to your wife
maybe you're right on track if stupid is
the norm you'll want to be weird America
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you